public sénat en partenariat avec le
magazine historia vous présente il était
une loi quand le sénat écrit l'histoire
[Musique]
là il
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir la
plus grande manifestation depuis la
libération a eu lieu aujourd'hui à paris
nous sommes en 1984 la france se déchire
la gauche au pouvoir vient de rallumer
la guerre scolaire en honorant une
promesse de françois mitterrand la mise
en place d'un service public unifié et
laïc de l'éducation nationale alors pour
ses partisans cette fois ci c'est la
bonne c'est la fin d'un combat de plus
d'un siècle pour mettre un terme à
l'emprise de l'église sur les écoles
mais pour ses opposants en inverse est
une atteinte insupportable à la liberté
d'enseignement quand ce n'est pas à leur
liberté tout court de janvier à juillet
des manifestations monstres se succèdent
des manoeuvres parlementaires aussi
déclenché la plus grave crise politique
du septennat et c'est ici au sénat que
sera donné le coup de grâce qui
provoquera la chute du gouvernement
comment les catholiques ont ils réussi à
faire essayer le pouvoir pourquoi les
laïcs ont ils perdu la guerre scolaire
et comment la gauche at elle fini par
abandonner un de ses ministres les plus
loyaux et les plus ouverts c'est
l'histoire que nous allons vous raconter
dans les têtes humour
[Musique]
je
mais pour comprendre les ressorts de
cette bataille il faut d'abord nous
replonger dans notre passé au 19e siècle
dans la france de 1850 plus précisément
à une époque où la république n'est
encore qu'un concept fragile et où
l'accès à l'enseignement n'est réservée
qu'à quelques-uns souvent les plus
fortunés bonjour bruno fuligni bonjour
vous êtes spécialiste de l'histoire
parlementaire nous allons revenir avec
vous sur les racines de cette guerre
scolaire et cette histoire elle commence
en 1850 par un projet de loi porté par
un homme alfred de fallou ministre de
l'instruction publique ont dit pas
encore ministre de l'éducation à
l'époque fallou résume son projet
politique de la façon suivante dieu dans
l'éducation le pape à la tête de
l'église et l'église à la tête de la
civilisation c'est donc un fervent
catholique que l'on confie sous la
deuxième république la mission de
repenser l'enseignement dans notre pays
avant la loi falloux il y à l'obligation
pour les communes de 500 habitants
d'avoir au moins une école élémentaire
pour garçons par ailleurs ça n'est pas
gratuit sauf pour les plus nécessiteux
les enfants de familles ouvrières ne
vont pas à l'école souvent ils
travaillent idem dans les bassins
miniers également dans l'agriculture il
ya un travail des enfants très important
ce qui veut dire que le système est très
inégalitaire pour les républicains de
1848 la question centrale c'est de
lutter contre ce qu'ils appellent
l'ignorance c'est de cela dont se
préoccupent les républicains de l'époque
alors il ya deux grandes tendances il ya
une tendance républicaine qui avaient un
projet très très large et très
démocratique mais qui effraie un petit
peu les conservateurs y compris les
conservateurs à la fal ou qui se
voudrait que les prêtres à s'agisse un
petit peu les esprits et en commençant
par par les plus jeunes il ya donc un
objectif politique derrière cette loi
falloux la loi falloux un objectif
politique et social très très clairs et
fallou très honnêtement d'ailleurs dira
que pour lui le premier devoir d'un
prêtre est d'enseigner aux pauvres la
résignation voilà donc on veut combattre
les idées démocratiques les idées
sociales voire socialisante qui ont
amené la révolution de 1848 et la
république à paris donc l'idée c'est de
confier vraiment l'instruction aux
prêtres donc la voilà cette loi falloux
on peut la regarder ensemble si vous
voulez elle consacre donc d'une certaine
façon la mainmise de l'église sur le
système éducatif oui nous avons ici un
exemplaire du moniteur universel le
journal officiel n'existe pas encore en
1850 et des articles 1er et bien on voit
que ce conseil supérieur de
l'instruction publique est dominé par
des religieux donc le but de cette loi
est très claire c'est de permettre aux
religieux et bien de retrouver
finalement l' influence qu'ils avaient
avant la révolution ces concessions a
fait à l'église avons irrité le camp
républicain c'est à dire que lors du
lors du débat de 1850 il y a en
particulier un éclat extraordinaire
c'est victor hugo lui n'est pas du tout
religieux il croit en dieu mais il n'est
pas favorable à une mainmise du clergé
sur l'instruction et donc ils attaquent
en des termes est extraordinaire ce
qu'il appelle le parti clérical et il
termine par ces mots extraordinaire et
évidemment c'est une gifle un pur pour
la majorité liberté d'enseigner liberté
d'enseignement ce que vous réclamez en
réalité c'est la liberté de ne pas
enseigner c'est à dire que victor hugo
accuse le parti clérical les
conservateurs et bien de vouloir
entretenir l'ignorance est l'erreur dit
il plutôt que de faire progresser les
lumières et dans le discours que
prononcera it origo le 15 janvier 1850
il va plus loin il indique qu'elle est
selon lui la voie à suivre et il indique
que pour lui c'est difficile il en
convient mais il faut aboutir à
l'instruction gratuite et obligatoire et
il faudra attendre trente ans plus tard
pour pourvoir ce vieux rêve de victor
hugo prendre forme avec avec les lois
ferry jules ferry c'est le père de
l'instruction laïque ils ont que jules
ferry donc à partir de 1879 et pendant
plusieurs années jusqu'en 1886 va être à
l'origine d'une série de mesures des
décrets et puis deux grandes lois qui
vont et bien
revenir sur la loi falloux et laïcisé
l'enseignement en même temps qu'ils le
démocratise les deux vont de pair alors
tenez elles sont dans les lois ferry on
va les regarder ensemble
[Musique]
[Rires]
voir qu'il ya plusieurs lois ferry ici
nous en avons eu tout à fait
intéressante alors qui est au stade du
projet de loi elle est présentée par
jules grévy qui est le président de la
république et jules ferry qui est à la
fois président du conseil des chefs du
gouvernement et ministre de
l'instruction publique et des beaux-arts
dans les lois ferry il ya l'idée de
s'adresser à l'ensemble des français
c'est à dire que l'instruction devient
obligatoire je dis bien de l'instruction
on peut toujours instruire des enfants
chez soi avec un précepteur cette
liberté continue d'exister mais c'est
obligatoire comme c'est obligatoire et
que certains parents n'ont pas les
moyens de le faire à domicile il faut
donc des écoles publiques gratuites et
donc une autre loi va instituer la
gratuité de l'enseignement et comme et
toutes les familles n'ont pas les mêmes
convictions religieuses et bien cette
école publique gratuite elle doit être
aussi laïque c'est à dire que
démocratisation et laïcisation vont de
pair avec là aussi un projet politique
faire en sorte que l'ensemble des petits
français quelles que soient leur
département de naissance quelles que
soient leurs origines sociales et bien
être un socle commun et aussi des
références communes y compris en matière
historique c'est en cela que cet
enseignement et démocratique c'est qu'au
fond tout petit français est un futur
citoyen et ses lois ferry vont
déclencher la colère des catholiques à
l'époque il faut voir que les lois ferry
ne sont pas
adopté dans un climat serein et lorsque
les républicains arrivent au pouvoir ils
commencent par l'expulsion des
congrégations ce sont plus de 250 écoles
religieuses qui sont fermés il ya
vraiment un contexte de guerre scolaire
de guerre religieuse les lois ferry
interviennent dans ce contexte là ici
donc les ferments de cette guerre
scolaire qui va durer pendant un siècle
à la fin des années 70 françois
mitterrand composent son programme dans
la perspective de l'élection
présidentielle de 1981 et il consacre
donc sa promesse numéro 90 à la
constitution d'un service public unifié
et laïc de l'éducation nationale on se
rend pas forcément compte aujourd'hui
mais dans les années 70 le mouvement
laïque c'est quelque chose dans la
politique française oui il faut voir
aussi que dans les années 60-70 la
pratique religieuse l'influencent du du
clergé recule beaucoup et que la gauche
regagne du terrain y compris une gauche
alors non seulement une gauche laïque à
l'ancienne et hocine gauche marxiste ou
marxisante donc dans certains
départements le vieil affrontements
entre cléricaux et anticléricaux devient
une bataille droite gauche dans les
termes nouveaux qui sont ceux des années
60 des années 70
[Musique]
janvier 1984 voilà bientôt trois ans que
le gouvernement mauroy peine à mettre en
oeuvre la promesse numéro 90 de françois
mitterrand il faut dire que c'est une
mission particulièrement difficile et
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela qu'elle a été
confiée à un homme de dialogue et
équilibre le ministre de l'éducation
nationale alain savary depuis son
arrivée rue de grenelle celui ci
applique la feuille de route que lui a
fixé le président il s'agit de
convaincre et non contraindre le
ministre enchaîne donc les discussions
les consultations les négociations les
versions du texte évolué mais le projet
ne satisfait ni les laïcs ni les
défenseurs de l'école libre en ce début
d'année ces derniers dans une série de
manifestations tous les dimanches pour
faire pression sur le gouvernement à
bordeaux puis lyon puis rennes puis
lille chaque fois la mobilisation
surprend la foule est énorme
bonjour bernard tout le monde bonjour
mathieu croissandeau en 1984 vous êtes
directeur des affaires générales au
ministère de l'éducation nationale et ce
projet de loi vous en avez été un des
négociateurs un des artisans
quel était l'objectif d'origine de ce
grand service public unifié et laïc de
l'éducation nationale l'origine textuel
dans les 110 propositions de mitterrand
c'est la 90e l'idée elle est au fond
d'essayer de mettre fin à la querelle
scolaire la guerre scolaire qui a ravagé
sur le plan politique notre pays depuis
quasiment un siècle alors très vite
quand les défenseurs de l'école libre
vont entendre parler de ce pollen de ce
service public unifié l'éducation
nationale ils vont y voir la mainmise de
l'état sur l'enseignement privé et même
une forme de nationalisation c'était le
cas alors mais l'ambiguïté de la formule
fait que les lie pur et dur l'interprète
comme la nationalisation dont il rêve
depuis toujours la nationalisation de
l'enseignement primaire dans un service
unique dans une entité unique
mais en face la droite et l'enseignement
privé l'interprète aussi comme ça et
redoute que ça prenne cette tournure là
aussi donc en réalité les esprits si
vous voulez interprète le grand spi
rennes comme un danger pour les arts est
au contraire comme une victoire pour les
autres voilà je voudrais vous nous
racontiez qui était annonce avarie est
ce que pour vous des l'homme de la
situation alors c'est un homme de
dialogue et la nomme de négociations
c'était un homme courage courageux parce
que le 18 juin il se trouve directement
auprès du général de gaulle et pour être
me lisez éducation nationale et pour
remplir la mission que lui donne le
président de la république et vaut mieux
être courageux d'ailleurs mitterrand lui
a dit si je vous mets s'est confié cette
mission elle est impossible c'est parce
que c'est vous mitterrand
sur cette affaire il a toujours pris
avec distance et de ce point de vue
il avait assorti d'ailleurs de d'une
lettre le 1er mai
1981 il a envoyé une lettre aux parents
d'élèves de renseignement privé où il
explique que sa proposition numéro 90 le
grand spi l'aisne c'est une proposition
pour lequel il entend convaincre et non
contraindre que ce il y aura ni
spoliation ni monopole et ses lunettes
et d'ailleurs alain savary c'est la
seule directive qui n'est jamais une
mitterrand si on le sujet se promener
toujours avec dans un transparent blanc
la lettre la copie de la lettre e denis
terrain parce que mitterrand n'a reçu
que trois ou quatre fois alain savary
sur ce sujet là l'enseignement primaire
alors à l'époque le pouvoir socialiste
et l'enseignement privé ce sont deux
mondes qui ne se connaissent pas du tout
il ya une anecdote qui a raconté pierre
daniel qui était donc le président de
l'association de parents d'élèves de
l'école libre à l'époque et qui explique
qu' une des premières fois où une
délégation se rend au ministère de
l'éducation nationale et que alain
savary leur propose un café et certains
membres de la délégation qui refera café
parce que c'est un ministère de gauche
qui le leur propose tout à fait parce
que dans les dirigeants de
l'enseignement catholique
pas plus d'ailleurs que dans les chais
les laïcs il n'y avait uniformité de
position est une figure qui se détache
c'est le chanoine paul guiberteau
guiberteau justement va remplacer le
secrétaire-général en place les nommer
comme l'interlocuteur
du gouvernement pour la faire de
l'enseignement privé est d'ailleurs les
premières rencontres avec le père
guiberteau ont lieu je peux le dire
aujourd'hui ont lieu chez madame
delachenal soeur de françois mitterrand
dans un appartement tue près du parc
monceau nous y allions d'ailleurs avec
des ruses de sioux qs genre gazole et
moi et nous rencontrions là le père
guiberteau madame delachenal nous
accueillait jeu nous offrait l'apéritif
et s'en aller gentiment elle nous
laissait et donc pendant quelques
semaines nous avons eu des réunions
régulières chez la soeur de président de
la république
on a vu d'où un signe qu'ils allaient
très bien parce que à l'intérieur
réunion le père guiberteau accepté lui
ce qu'il refusait toujours jusque là
mais en janvier il est désavoué par le
comité national de l'enseignement
catholique celle qui réunit toutes les
forces tellement catholique et donc ça
nous a montré que paul guiberteau
n'avait pas l'autorité sur ses troupes
d'où le fait que ensuite on a joué une
autre carte beaucoup plus importante qui
était celle de pierre daniel le
représentant des parents d'élèves leur
danse en temps des parents et de l'autre
côté il ya le camp laïc et les laïcs qui
vous met la pression et alors le corps
laïque est aussi complètement divisé les
ultras ils sont fort nombreux les ultras
c'est en particulier au sein du canal du
comité national d'action laïque comité
national d'action laïque qui regroupe
pour l'essentiel des syndicats ou des
organisations de l'enseignement public
eux ce sont les purs et durs alors ce
sont les purs et durs le cnal et est
extrêmement intransigeant ils sont pas
les seuls on trouve au parti socialiste
mais aussi des courants et donc on a des
mouvements et sans que le ps le parti
socialiste n'arrive vraiment à trouver
une position
commune qui fasse l'unanimité ils sont
divisés donc tout le monde fonctionne un
peu au jugé et à vinça seront jugés ce
printemps 1984 il ya eu trois années de
consultations de discussions avec les
différents partenaires de l'enseignement
privé ou ou des laïcs et ça a abouti à
l'élaboration d'un projet de loi un
projet de loi très technique très
complexe gelé la sous les yeux vous de
voir téhéran sens plénier beaucoup en
disant que j'étais trop technique
c'était même mal écrire d une fois ne
serait ce que son titre projet de loi
relatif au rapport entre l'état les
communes les départements les régions et
les établissements d'enseignement privés
parce qu'il est question aussi de
décentralisation de l'humain dans ce
texte ce texte et si technique si
complexe que ça va en gros faciliter une
forme de désinformation une forme
d'instrumentalisation parlera par ses
adversaires c'est vrai mais comment
faire autrement effectivement nous
pensions bien que ce texte était très
très technique mais les négociateurs
qu'est-ce qui réclamaient que les gens
se prenaient les choses soient écrites
noir sur blanc et soient précises car il
craignait qu'un jour voilà on
l'interprète d'une autre manière donc on
était pris entre deux feux l' affaire
était d'autant plus compliquée à
résoudre que on y introduisait la
décentralisation ont rénové donc tous
les rapports entre les collectivités
territoriales et les établissements
privés on y introduisait des éléments de
rénovation du système éducatif
si on essaie de résumer ou ici j'ai bien
compris les négociations elles bloquent
en fait sur deux points la question du
financement et la question du statut des
enseignants du privé que le gouvernement
souhaite notamment titularisé le
financement le problème ne se posait en
réalité que pour les écoles parce que ce
sont les communes qui vers ce qu'on
appelle le forfait d'externat
c'est-à-dire un forfait une subvention à
l'établissement pour ses dépenses de
fonctionnement et le deuxième point sur
la titularisation des enseignants
pourquoi ça bloquait la grande affaire
parce que l'enseignement privé y voyait
un levier
vers l'intégration et la
fonctionnarisation de l'enseignement
privé et lier les laïcs n'hésitez pas à
dire que le cheval de troie dans les
établissements privés ça allait être les
maîtres titulaire justement alors à
partir de janvier 1984 les
manifestations s'enchaînent dans
plusieurs villes dans région à bord et
puis il ya un premier point d'or qui est
versailles le 4 mars avec entre services
aux remises voici cent mille
manifestants 800000 disent les
organisateurs le loch venus de toute la
france et des politiques qui s'emmène à
ce moment là les manifestants semblent
avoir gagné une première bataille qui
est celle de la communication tout à
fait parce que leur combat pour l'école
libre s'est mué en combat pour la
liberté est ce que vous aviez conscience
d'avoir perdu cette bataille d'image à
l'époque absolument on s'est bien aperçu
que à cause des lay pur et dur nous
perdions la bataille de la liberté et
c'est au nom de la liberté que ces
manifestants dans les rues réclamaient
la liberté de l'enseignement et la
liberté tout court le 18 avril le projet
de loi que vous avez préparé avec alain
savary arrive sur la table du conseil
des ministres et françois mitterrand
exige qu'il soit revu en détail au
conseil malik est une circonstance assez
rare une procédure assez rare avec
minutie le chef de l'état reprend même
ici ou là quelques mots quelques fautes
de ponctuation que et puis à la fin il
demande à chaque ministre de se
prononcer sur le texte ça aussi c'est
très rare à cette époque ce 18 avril
vous êtes confiant dans l'avenir de ce
texte
alors au marché sur des oeufs
parce que nous avions
je peux pas dire un accord mais nous
avions mois là du côté de l'enseignement
catholique
les pierres daniel et le père guiberteau
nous disait bon oui ça on est on est par
contre voilà et donc nous étions
confiants si vous voulez de ce côté par
contre on les témoins du côté des laïcs
et en particulier les parlementaires
qu'est ce qui est fait tout basculer
assez les amendements laignel bien
entendu les miels avait été président
d'une commission spéciale car le
parlement avait voté une commission
spéciale
et arguant du fait qu'il était président
de cette commission il a élaboré des
amendements avec un certain nombre
d'autres parlementaires pierre joxe eaux
prennent
ils ont fait le siège de pierre mauroy
jour et nuit ils ont fait le ciel de
pierre mauroy pour imposer leurs
amendements
avec son projet loi alain savary croit
tenir un compromis son texte est
aussitôt transmis à l'assemblée
nationale qui fixe sa discussion au 21
mai mais l affaire va très vite lui
échapper car dans la majorité les laïcs
gronde et se font entendre pour eux le
ministre de l'éducation nationale a
beaucoup trop cédé à l'enseignement
privé ils voient ce projet comme un
reniement comme une abdication un an
plus tôt en 1983 les socialistes ont
déjà eu du mal à avaler le tournant de
la rigueur économique la déroute du ps
aux municipales alors pour eux
évidemment pas question de renoncer à ce
qu'il considère comme un marqueur de
gauche du septennat pour vous donner une
idée de l'ambiance en octobre 1983 au
congrès du ps à bourg en bresse ain et
du soleil et monte à la tribune pour
prononcer cette petite phrase qui en dit
long il ne peut y avoir qu'une seule
école celle de la république cet homme
c'est andré laignel
pour l'enseignement catholique
ce petit homme est-il le diable andré
laignel député-maire socialiste
d'issoudun s'en défend et ici toute la
gauche est assez coûte
soutenir farouchement la laïcité n'est
pas une diableries dit il mais une
attitude logique pour un socialiste un
extrémiste une formule que rejette non
seulement les socialistes aux locaux
mais bon nombre d'enseignants et de
parents d'élèves il dépasse beaucoup
d'autres débats que nous avons pu avoir
je partage ce qui le concerne
entièrement les études
[Musique]
que je pense qu'il est important oui de
défendre en priorité
bonjour andré laignel bonjour en 1984
vous êtes le député maire d'issoudun une
ville dont vous êtes d'ailleurs toujours
maire aujourd'hui et vous allez prendre
la tête de la fronde laïque contre le
projet savary tout d'abord avant de
rentrer dans le détail je voudrais
comprendre ce que représentait pour vous
à l'époque cette promesse de françois
mitterrand la promesse 90 pour moi
c'était une promesse importante c'était
d'avoir un grand service public laïque
et unifiée de l'éducation nationale
c'est à dire donner un véritable
caractère républicain et national à
l'éducation
et à partir du moment où cet engagement
ne m'a pas semblé tenu alors je les dis
on va y venir à issoudun pour se
replonger un peu dans l'époque à
issoudun vous aviez entamé un même un
bras de fer juridique à propos des
subventions que devait verser la commune
à l'enseignement privé que vous aviez
refusé d'inscrire dans votre budget je
m'étais engagé lorsque j'étais devenue
mère à maintenir les subventions
existantes mais à ne pas en donner de
nouvelles et c'est la promesse que j'ai
tenus c'était une forme de désobéissance
civile à l'époque non c'était simplement
le caractère laïc de la constitution qui
faisaient qu'il n'y avait pas de raison
que nous financions l'école privée alors
on s'en rend peut-être un peu moins
compte aujourd'hui à notre époque mais
le mouvement laïque dans les années 80 à
la fin des années 70 c'est quelque chose
de puissant en france racontez nous
c'est est un principe républicain
j'allais dire au centre des réflexions
des idées logis et des philosophies ce
qui va plus loin et c'était évidemment
la résurgence de l'idéal révolutionnaire
et ce mouvement laïc il était très
présent au parti socialiste au début des
années 80 c'est vrai qu'il y avait
beaucoup de députés qui étaient issus de
ce qu'on appelait les hussards de la
république
ces enseignants souvent du premier degré
qui se donnait totalement à leur mission
éducative et qui considérait que la
laïcité était la préservation de la
république elle-même alors le 25 avril
1984 en réaction au mont grande
manifestation qu'on a pu connaître de la
part de l'enseignement privé il ya une
grande manifestation laïque qui est
organisé par le cnam il est trop tôt
pour donner des chiffres disons qu'il y
à déjà des dizaines et des dizaines de
milliers de personnes peut-être beaucoup
plus cher locale le comité national
d'action laïque qui ouvre le défilé
les responsables politiques et syndicaux
vous y étiez dans cette manifestation
bien sûr bien sûr j'avais été invité par
le cnal le comité national d'action
laïque un mouvement puissant qui avait
ses entrées à matignon à l'elysée oui
bien sûr bien sûr beaucoup étaient issus
de l'éducation populaire à commencer par
le premier ministre lui-même pierre
mauroy qui présidait la fédération léo
lagrange qui est une des grandes
fédérations d'éducation populaire qui
existe encore aujourd'hui que
reprochez-vous alors au projet savary à
sa sortie du conseil des ministres le 18
avril 84 il est là ce projet savary je
sais pas si vous vous en souvenez si on
peut regarder on a quelques articles
quels sont les articles souvenez des
articles ça ici on les regarde on
sentait plus j'allais dire
l'ensemble qui posait problème si on
prend un article par article il y en a
beaucoup qui posait pas de difficultés
mais d'abord la promesse n'étaient pas
tenus puisque la notion même de service
public unifié unifié et laïc n'était pas
repris dans le texte de loi parce que
c'était considéré comme une provocation
ce terme là cette grande expression un
peu obscur pour le profane c'est pas une
provocation
c'est est le résultat de vingt ans de
réflexion sur ce que devait être
l'éducation nationale dans notre pays
c'était pas du tout improvisé c'était
dans les propositions de françois
mitterrand et ça n'avait pas été écrit
sur un coin de table alain savary pour
vous avez trahi ou avait trop cédé à
l'enseignement privé je veux dire alain
savary était un homme de qualité un
homme de devoir et un honnête homme mais
alain savary c'est plus lente et dès le
début il a cru qu'il pouvait concilier
avec des gens qui n'avaient aucune envie
de concilier je parle de l'école privée
ce grand service public unifié de
l'éducation nationale c'était la mort de
l'enseignement privé non se saouler en
aucun cas sa mort ça se voulait au
contraire son intégration sa prise en
compte et ça ne l'interdisait pas qu'il
puisse y avoir des écoles privées par
ailleurs mais pas dans le cadre du
service public alors avant même que le
projet de loi ne soit examiné à
l'assemblée nationale vous allez décider
de l'amendé vous allez décider de le
modifier de le faire évoluer vous aviez
conscience à l'époque de détricoter ce
compromis que pensait avoir trouvé à nos
salariés
la conviction
j'étais partagé par la majorité et la
grande majorité du groupe socialiste qui
étaient majoritaires au parlement à
cette époque était que ça n'avait aucune
chance d'aboutir
et donc j'ai effectivement proposer des
amendements au nom du groupe par les
amendements ou des ordres laignel non ça
a été un travail de groupe et un travail
qui a été validé par l'immense majorité
du groupe socialiste à l'assemblée tenez
ils sont là vos amendements est ce que
vous aviez conscience on les déposants
de durcir le texte d'alain savary est ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer ce qu'il
contenait l'objectif n'était pas de
durcir mais de rendre acceptables par
les laïcs une loi qu'il n'était pas leur
idéal et ses amendements le premier il
prévoyait que des emplois ne pourront
être affectés à de nouvelles classes pré
élémentaire privée que dans la mesure où
dans la même commune fonctionne déjà au
moins une classe pré élémentaire
publique c'est que vous ne vouliez pas
concrètement qu'il y ait un
établissement privé qui s'ouvre s'il n'y
avait pas déjà un établissement public
très exactement donc ce n'était pas du
tout une exclusion du privé c'était une
volonté que le public soit présent
également ça c'était le premier
amendement voyez que il n'a rien de
liberticide
quant au deuxième c'était simplement de
soumettre le maintien des contrats entre
l'état et les établissements privés à la
condition que la moitié des mètres de
l'établissement soit intégré dans la
fonction publique à l'issue voyez qu'on
était vraiment très large d'un délai de
sept à neuf ans ce qui l'est c'est tout
le temps des transitions tel est
conditionnée donc les aides de l'état
plus des communes au fait que la moitié
des enseignants soient titularisés alors
il ya quelque chose qui est difficile à
comprendre pour nous aujourd'hui c'est
que ces amendements en fait vous allez
en discuter avec pierre mauroy lui-même
avant même que les débats ne s'ouvre à
l'assemblée nationale et tout ça va se
faire dans une réunion à huit clos 100
premiers concernés c'est à dire sans un
an savary le ministre de l'éducation
nationale racontez-nous effectivement
pire au gourou a souhaité me rencontrer
comment pourrais-je dire non au premier
ministre encore plus à un ami donc je
suis allé lui expliquer la démarche du
groupe socialiste pour qu'il comprenne
bien que
le risque était l'échec s'il continuer
sur la même voie concrètement pour bien
comprendre on a un premier ministre de
gauche qui présente un projet de loi
d'un ministre de l'éducation de gauche
et qui se retrouve face à un députés du
groupe majoritaire qui lui expliquent au
fond que ses propres troupes ne voterons
pas ce texte c'est ça que vous voulez
dire que les socialistes étaient prêts à
ne pas voter ou à voter contre sa mère
c'est clair c'est clair que
sans les amendements que j'ai proposé et
qui était très mineur par rapport au
fond très mineures
ça ne serait pas passé devant le groupe
donc il c'est de penser à cette réunion
purement il constate vous souvenez des
débats à l'assemblée à l'époque
globalement tu aurais pas bon si ces
violences étaient en angleterre c'est
tendu oui bien sûr ça a été assez tendu
mais vous savez c'est étendus dans la
rue
moi je suis reçue
probablement plus de 1000 lettres de
menaces de mort sur les allemands par
seulement sur moi en disant on s'en
prendre à votre fils
il y avait une une passion qui tournait
à la haine chez certains
mais je suis pas sûr qu'il ya eu
beaucoup
d'épisodes qui a conduit une telle
déferlante parce que ça dit quelque
chose oui de de ce que ce projet doit
toucher du doigt d'une certaine ça c'est
parce que pour ses opposants faut le
rappeler au 6e considéré que c'était une
atteinte insupportable à ceux qui se
considéraient être leur liberté
probablement sûrement ça n'était pas le
cas ce qu'on est libre dans l'école de
la république et je ne peux pas accepter
l'idée qu'on ne seraient pas libres dans
l'école de la république mais sans doute
que tout cas les plus extrémistes
d'entre eux étaient dans cette pensée
que l'ue mette dans l'école de la
république c'est lé maître de l'école du
diable j'ai reçu les courriers qui
disait vous êtes le diable incarné
voulait que nos enfants soient dans les
écoles du diable est ce que vous aviez
conscience du coût de avec ses
amendements de déclencher ce qui allait
devenir une vraie crise politique est
sans doute une des plus grosses crises
politiques du septennat du premier
septennat de françois mitterrand savait
que c'était tendu on savait que c'était
difficile de là à créer une crise
politique la démission du premier
ministre et du ministre de l'éducation
très honnêtement ça n'a jamais été dans
nos pensées et surtout pendant nos
souhaits
[Musique]
après le vote à l'assemblée la réaction
des défenseurs de l'école libre ne se
fait pas attendre furieux de ce coup de
force il appelle à une manifestation
nationale à paris le 24 juin ce jour là
dans les rues de la capitale c'est une
marée humaine
les centaine de délégations venues des
quatre coins du pays et de toutes les
académies par trains spéciaux 6 milles
carrés plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
voitures brandissaient pancartes et
banderoles à la gloire de l'école libre
et trois cortèges convergent vers la
place de la bastille tout un symbole
sous les banderoles où s'affiche en gros
le mot liberté la foule reprend en
choeur l'ère des esclaves de verdi dont
on a transformé les paroles ils sont 850
milles sur la police mais deux millions
pour les organisateurs c'est du jamais
vu depuis la libération des trésors
d'autres convois déversées sur le pavé
de paris des centaines de milliers
d'autres défenseurs de l'école libre
venus de l'ouest et de la bretagne
pour la gauche qui vient de subir une
énième débâcle le week-end précédent aux
élections européennes c'est un
tremblement de terre et pendant ce
temps-là au sénat où le texte a été
transmis on s'interroge la droite
majoritaire est évidemment opposés au
texte mais les sénateurs savent bien que
c'est une bataille perdue d'avancé
puisque au bout du compte c'est à
l'assemblée nationale que reviendra le
dernier mot alors quelle stratégie
adopter c'est la question qui courent au
palais du luxembourg
bonjour josselin de rohan bonjour en
1984 vous êtes sénateur rpr du morbihan
vous venez d'être élu un an plus tôt
qu'est-ce que vous reprochiez sur le
fond à ce projet de loi savary c'est
très simple c'était une nationalisation
déguisée de l'enseignement catholique
d'enseignement privé pourtant le texte
avait été le fruit d'une forme de
compromis élaboré avec alain savary et
les représentants de l'enseignement
privé il ya eu un durcissement à
l'assemblée nationale 1 du fait de la
majorité de l'époque et une très grande
méfiance de la part des dirigeants de
l'enseignement catholique parce que
andré laignel lui nous dit que ces
amendements n'ont pas durci le texte ce
que c'était au fond des amendements
techniques il dit ce qu'il veut
nous nous avons constaté sur pièce que
c'était manifestement une mise au pas et
plus que ça de l'enseignement catholique
et utilise une disparition à terme de sa
liberté quand on met son enfant dans une
école catholique sait très bien pourquoi
on le fait en principe en tout cas on
sait qu'on va avoir un projet spécifique
devant soi qui se réfère à une morale
une éthique particulière en cette année
1984 une série de grandes manifestations
lancées par notamment les parents
d'élèves de l'enseignement libre avec un
point d'orgue de cette manifestation
parisienne du 24 juin vous avez
manifesté vous pendant cette année 84
notre budget était manifesté à rennes
une énorme manifestation
ce qui est très clair c'est que toutes
ces manifestations sont nées de la base
ç'a vraiment été un réflexe des parents
très bien compris ce qui était en jeu et
par conséquent c'est quand même souvent
poussé leur hiérarchie je peux même vous
dire que il a fallu quelques fois poussé
des évêques qui n'était pas très
déterminés à se mouiller mais même le
pape sont aimés les en donnant son avis
depuis rome il dit le 29 juin les
catholiques ont le droit et le devoir de
défendre leur école donc si on n'était
plus seulement dans une bataille
politique on était dans un enjeu
sociétal un enjeu c'est comme ça que
notre civilisation d'une séquence
senteurs tout cas c'est
dans le camp d'en face
c'était bien c'était bien le parti
qu'ils avaient pris de lutter contre un
enseignement
qui sort jamais eu beaucoup de plaisir à
accepter les mouvements et les
manifestations elles sont le fait de
parents d'élèves de l'enseignement libre
au départ au départ est ce que vous
diriez que la droite a d'une certaine
façon récupérer le mouvement non le
soutenu
c'était nos électeurs
j'étais en phase totale avec mes
administrés comme maire ou ou comme
conseiller général mais c'était aussi un
des premiers moyens de contrer cette
gauche au pouvoir qui était là depuis
1980 avec un vrai débat soutenu par
l'opinion publique pour nous en a fourni
l'occasion parce que je veux voir que
cette salle ça se situe à l'époque du
socialisme triomphant le majorité
écrasante à l'assemblée nationale très
lié avec des communistes de népotisme
est très combative
imposant des réformes très importantes
quand même puis se sont pas seulement
des nationalisations par les
organisations bon et là il se trouve que
à mon avis c'est le premier faux pas qui
c'est qu'ils avaient qu'ils avaient
commis et on n'allait tout de même pas
laisser passer l'occasion alors c'était
une occasion de s'opposer humeurs
combattives au sénat mais comment
s'opposer à ce texte parce qu'on
rappelle que vous saviez très bien que
dans le jeu les règles parlementaires
c'est à l'assemblée nationale que
revient le dernier mot vous avez hésité
sur la stratégie à suivre au sein du
groupe au sénat y avait un leader de
l'opposition qui était charles pasqua
est incontestablement lui qui était à la
manoeuvre racontez nous un petit qui
était la seule qui était charles pasqua
était une figure politique et les paumes
agents pasqua c'était quelqu'un qui a
est un vieux gaulliste qui avait été un
des compagnons du général il avait été
député
après 1968 puis il est arrivé au sénat
il a très vite pris la présidence du
groupe dès qu'il est arrivé au sénat il
est devenu l'animateur de l'opposition
parce que c'était quelqu'un de très
intelligent
très ingénieux un sachant parfaitement
utiliser les ressources du règlement du
sénat pour pouvoir se poser et il avait
acquis beaucoup d'influencé compris
d'ailleurs sur le président power il est
très proche du président power charles
pasqua ou l époque oui et le président
pères il cherche la manoeuvre à suivre
il cherche le l'astuce qui permettra de
contrer efficacement ce projet du
gouvernement la suite je vous propose
que d'écouter charles pasqua c'est lui
qui nous la raconte
oui l'emporté avec lequel j'avais des
relations très très suivi
me demande d'aller le voir il me dit
j'ai demandé à voir françois mi temps je
vais le voir avec quatre amendements qui
devraient permettre de régler tout ça
sente histoire
je lui ai dit je vous retrouve bien
optimiste il est parti voir françois mi
temps je me rappelle j'étais sur le
boulevard saint germain lorsque l'on m'a
fait chercher on manie le programme
poher
viennent de rentrer il veut revoir
d'urgence il me dit ça s'est très mal
passé il a refusé toute discussion et il
m'a dit vous avez déjà fait partir un
paysan de la république vous ne me ferez
pas partir en 2d je n'accepterai aucune
discussion
alors
alain poyart me dis je vois pas trop ce
qu'on m'a pouvant faire moi je vais
réfléchir un tueur allemande trop temps
et je m'étais dit il y a une seule
parade mais peut-être que ça va vous
paraître excessif et difficile à mettre
en oeuvre le dicôlon jeudi c'est l'appel
référendum
le président power a été très heurté
dans sa manière de concevoir les choses
par l'attitude de mitterrand et donc par
conséquent il a trouvé en pasqua
quelqu'un qui était prêt un des
initiatives
permettait de mener un combat qu'est ce
que vous en avez pensé quand il l'a
proposé cette initiative de référendum
toi que c'était une très bonne idée
parce que c'était un moyen d'abord
d'embarrasser sérieusement le président
refusait de consulter le peuple c'est
quand même quelque chose qui est enfin
sur le plan de la démocratie c'est à sa
pureté 1 donc c'était une bonne idée et
alors cette proposition de référendum
elle fait l'objet d'une motion mais une
motion que vous avez signé mais il y à
votre nom josselin de rohan
cette motion en fait elle va bloquer
l'examen sur le fond du texte savary
l'idée c'était de le bloquer en
demandant l'arbitrage du peuple et vous
n'avez pas regretter de ne pas avoir
examiné ce projet de loi savary sur le
fond d'avoir fait entendre et valoir vos
arguments ne l'avons pas refaite pas
examiné croyez bien que il ya eu
beaucoup de réunions préparatoires au
sénat pour examiner le texte en
commission notamment en commission mais
en dehors de ça il ya eu des groupes de
travaux informel et elle
doit exister dans les groupes j'ai
participé à l'un d'entre eux et nous
avons entendu monseigneur guiberteau
enfin et tous les responsables de
l'enseignement public
donc nous avions une idée tout à fait
arrêtée sur ce texte mais en prenant
cette initiative
ça a permis de faire capoter le texte et
in fine est de faire tomber le
gouvernement vous attendiez à ça alors
nous n'avions pas bien dans l'idée de
faire tomber le gouvernement parce que
le sénat n'a pas la possibilité de faire
nous ne venons pas des motions de
censure nous ne pouvions pas le faire
comme à l'assemblée par exemple non ce
qui se passait c'est que mon avis
l'opposition très ferme du sénat ne
reflétaient l'opinion être l'opposition
très forte d'une très très large partie
de la population qui avaient manifesté
dans les rues là je vais vous donner un
à côté une anecdote le jour de la grande
manifestation
de paris le 24 juin françois mitterrand
demande à jacques chaumont mon collègue
jack chaumont sénateur de la sarthe ce
chaumont est ce que vous allez
participer cet après midi à la grande
manifestation
et chaumont lui dit oui monsieur le
président de la république elle lui dit
mitterrand vous y rencontrerez la moitié
de ma famille donc que ça vous donne une
mesure de l'émotion générale mais c'est
le sénat qui a donné le coup de grâce à
ce gouvernement mauroy où il a il a
donné un coup de pioche est ce que le
sénat a outrepassé ses droits
pas du tout il était parfaitement d'un
saumon dans son rôle il se trouve que
c'était une majorité de droite qui était
dans l'opposition
ce la démocratie
le 5 juillet le sénat adopte la motion
proposant un référendum sur
l'enseignement privé françois mitterrand
est tendue en déplacement au puy en
velay en auvergne il s'exprime pour la
première fois sur le sujet je ne
renoncerai à rien dit il et pourtant
sept jours plus tard le même françois
mitterrand annonce en direct à la
télévision le retrait du projet de loi
savary entraînant dans la foulée la
chute de son gouvernement le
gouvernement déposera un nouveau projet
de loi fixant les rapports entre l'état
les communes les départements les
régions et l'enseignement privé sur les
points qui relève à l'évidence des
procédures habituelles
bonjour jean louis bianco bonjour en
1984 vous êtes secrétaire général de
l'elysée vous êtes donc un des plus
proches collaborateurs de françois
mitterrand et en ce début juillet le
président de la république que par est
coincé par l'initiative du sénat qui a
été de demander un référendum sur le
projet savary quelle ambiance règne à
l'elysée je crois qu'à l'elysée tout le
monde à peu près compris que j'avais pas
brûler ce poire que ce projet de loi
dans sa forme finale telle que les
résultats d'innombrables pas là pour
mener par savary avec tout le monde est
une chance de passer de moi je n'ai pas
le souvenir que françois mitterrand se
sentait coincé parce que c'est
finalement grâce à pasqua et au sénat
consonne est sorti grâce à tizi pasqua
qui dit faut faire un référendum et
françois mitterrand nous dira si moi
quelle excellente idée simplement
l'article 11 de la constitution ne
permet pas dans sa rédaction actuelle
nous faire un référendum sur le service
public unifié l'éducation nationale dont
il faut faire un référendum pour
modifier l'article 11 il fast close
modifié on pourra en effet faire le
référendum que c'était pasqua sauf que
naturellement il ya jamais eu de
référendum sur le référendum
c'est pasqua qui nous a aidés à passer
la charasse et mitterrand travailler
ensemble y compris d'ailleurs charasse
accompagnant mitterrand libye a surpris
tout le monde il est en train de gratter
pour ce référendum sur le référendum je
vous propose d'écouter cette annonce du
référendum sur le référendum par
françois mitterrand c'est dans une
allocution télévisée le 12 juillet
qu'il soit bien clair que je ne
considère pas qu'il soit illégitime ou
choquants qu' ici ou là on n'ait songé à
soumettre au référendum les nouvelles
dispositions sur l'école volume par le
gouvernement
ces dispositions traite en effet d'un
problème suffisamment important pour que
la souveraineté nationale puisse
s'exprimer de cette façon à ce sujet
encore faut-il que les institutions
l'autorisent
dans l'état présente notre droit ce
n'est pas le cas
le moment est venu d'engager la révision
constitutionnelle qui permettra au
président de la république
lorsqu'il le jugera utile est conforme à
l'intérêt du pays de consulter les
français sur les grandes questions qui
concernent c'est bien précieux
inaliénable que sont les libertés
publiques c'est une manoeuvre assez
habile ce référendum sur le référendum
c'est très habile et c'est frappant de
voir quand on l'entend la précision
extraodinaire des termes qui l'emploie
chaque mot est pesé chaque mois son
importance il n'emploie pas un terme
pour un autre et il quand andy lit dès
le début certains ici ou là on pensait à
référendum lee hsiu la cei a pas que moi
puisque pasqua et le sénat l'ont dit et
en fait alors que le sénat pensait le
mettre en difficulté en demandant un
référendum bien sûr nous qu'il aurait pu
vous probablement perdu dans l'opinion
publique lui retourne en proposant cette
autre référendum où la droite auraient
été forcés de voter et juridiquement
était imparable il fallait en effet
toucher à l'article 11 s'étaient pas
c'est pas seulement une manoeuvre
c'était une nécessité juridique et
constitutionnel et dans cette même
allocution il va annoncer d'une façon
assez sibylline le retrait du projet de
loi savary
c'est la conséquence logique il a trouvé
une échappatoire
il sait très bien qu'on va pas continuer
éternellement donc il le dit bien ce
soit compris dans les semaines et les
mois qui viennent une annonce pas
maintenant la nouvelle maintenant c'est
qu'on travaille sur le référendum sur
l'affairé noble et puis tu ça va
s'évanouir dans les sables le problème
c'est que le principal concerné alain
savary n'est pas en de l'abandon de son
projet de loi je vous propose d'écouter
bernard tout le monde nous le racontait
le 12 juillet à la savary n'a absolument
pas été prévenus à je peux en témoigner
puisque j'étais avec lui et c'est à la
télévision que nous l'avons appris
comment il l'a vécu ah ben c'est un
homme qui ne pleurait pas mais si ils
auraient pu pleurer voilà c'était la fin
si vous voulez d'une oeuvre de plusieurs
années de travail pour essayer dans
l'histoire
dans l'histoire de
terminer enfin la querelle scolaire
pourquoi ne pas avoir prévenu alain
savary parce que je pense que dans
l'esprit de françois mitterrand le
secret absolu était nécessaire je ne
sais pas dire qu'il était au courant à
part charasse par définition et moi
personne ne m'en a parlé j'en ai parlé à
personne je pense que céder car le
secret est indispensable à l'exécution
de la de la manoeuvre au centre
manoeuvres militaires
sait pas qu'il ya une défiance vis-à-vis
d'alain savary parce qu'on dit qu'il n'a
sacrifié oui mais il a il a beaucoup
travaillé pour essayer dès qu'ils ne
soient pas sacrifiées mais les souvenirs
de samedi matin dans le bureau du
président revoyez stylo à la main le
projet de loi de savary pour essayer de
l'améliorer de le rendre plus lisible et
compréhensible il ya passé des heures et
des heures c'est pas utiliser quelqu'un
qui veut envoyer savary à l'abattoir
alain savary va remettre sa démission
dans la foulée d'alain savary pierre
mauroy va démissionner
le premier ministre monsieur pierre
mauroy a présenté au président de la
république la démission de son
gouvernement
le président de la république a accepté
cette démission alors est-ce que c'est
lui qui est à l'origine de sa démission
ou est-ce que c'est françois mitterrand
qui l'a poussé à démissionner je ne sais
pas je pense que pierre mauroy jeu le
bla probabilité pour moi c'est quand
moreau a démissionné parce qu'il
trouvait ce n'était pas normal que
savary et si j'ose dire accessoirement
lui c'était quand même qu luminis n'en
soit après une chirurgie la pression qui
n'a pas été prévenu il se sentait
désavoué exactement on dit qu'il était
fatigué politiquement humainement oui
françois mitterrand voulait s'en séparer
à ce moment de son septennat françois
mitterrand mon avis était hésitant il
est hésitant parce qu'il avait un lien
affectif avec mauroy vraiment très
profond je pense que le moment où ils se
sont séparés est un des moments les plus
les plus rudes sur le plan affectif pour
mitterrand et pour moi je reviens à
françois mitterrand il avait reçu
l'éducation catholique lui quel regard
il avait son enseignement privé
il n'avait pas un regard négatif ce
qu'il ne supportait pas c'est le mot
école libre il ya l'école les copains
soit livre comme si l'école publique
n'était pas libre j'avais vu piquer des
vraies colères retirer des manifestes
des affiches faites par la droite avec
des barreaux derrière lesquelles on
voyait un enfant
qu'il fallait libérer pour attirer dans
l'école privée catholique il y tenait à
cette proposition numéro 90 du grand spi
lundi l'idée n'est pas ce qu'il avait
déjà fait un chemin il fait faire un
chemin au parti socialiste et à la
gauche avant le slogan des années 70
c'était argent public écoles publiques
argent privé écoles privées mais c'était
aussi on nationalise on nationalise
enseignement privé hors des 72 ans
programme commun et dans les propos de
françois mitterrand il fait toujours
attention à dire même quand il est
premier secrétaire il faut rassembler
les différentes formes d'enseignement
dans un grand service public rassemblé
s'est pas cassé c'est pas supprimé et
c'est d'ailleurs ce à quoi arrive le
projet savary avec le recul comment vous
expliquer cet échec du projet savary je
pense que l'échec était presque
inéluctable
quand on regarde le détail d'abord ce
pour des raisons historiques
philosophiques culturelles idéologiques
la laïcité française s'est bâtie sur une
guerre entre l'église catholique et
l'état notamment sur le contrôle des
consciences donc notamment sur
l'enseignement privé est ce que ce
projet il aurait pu voir le jour en tout
début de septennat
s'il avait été fait dans la foulée
l'élection de françois mitterrand non
parce que je pense qu'il fallait du
temps pour aboutir à ce à quoi savoir et
habile a abouti avec 7 cd le service
public local qui rassemble tous est une
idée très belle mais évidemment trop
girondine pour notre culture dominante
qui est très jacobine que chaque
français petits français le lundi matin
de 8 heures à 8 heures 15 face au même
cours sinon on n'est plus dans l'égalité
et qui avait eu un certain nombre de
clignotants qui s'était lui-même vous
même vous avez été l'auteur d'une note
oui c'est pas très optimiste à l'époque
surgir la vérité même inquiète dès le
départ quand ils ont commencé à recevoir
beaucoup de gens je me suis rendu compte
que c'était que dans le rapport de force
des manifestants et les deux ce qui se
disait sur la voie publique et laïque
été battus largement battu y compris des
sondages officieux
compris xavier les résultats et qui
montrait que l'immense a été attaché ça
se sentait parce que les français est
attaché pas parce qu'ils étaient
catholiques vous aimer l'école privée
parce qu'ils voulaient pas une solution
de rechange si leurs gosses marche mal à
l'école publique et ils avaient éteint
leurs cours cc des consommateurs en
génération de parents consommateurs
c'est pas du ratio de parents idéologues
[Musique]
bonjour alain chabod bonjour en 1984
vous êtes journaliste politique vous
avez donc suivi cette bataille cet
épisode de la guerre scolaire d'abord
quelle image quel souvenir en gardez
vous comme tout le monde la grande
manifestation du jeu c'était tellement
incroyable de voir la droite qui
effectivement avait investi la rue la
rue c'est la gauche bien entendu mais là
c'était incroyable toute la droite
mobiliser tous côte-à-côte main dans la
main il avait remporté la victoire
politique qu'ils attendaient depuis qui
trônait à quel moment avez vous senti
que l'échec était inhabitable pendant
cette manifestation laquelle vous
faisait allusion ou juste après bien
avant en fait parce que il ya eu
évidemment les ibères parlementaire il
ya eu des projets qui étaient mis sur la
table puis enterré puis modifiée en fait
l'elysée matignon et au parti socialiste
franchement tout le monde était à des
degrés divers très réservé très mesurée
à l'égard de ce projet est au fond
françois mitterrand avait déjà dit que
20 83 dans mon souvenir on pourrait
jamais mettre tout le monde d'accord
c'était irréconciliables déjà et alors
cette guerre scolaire elle va provoquer
une crise gouvernementale avec la chute
du gouvernement mauroy ils étaient usés
pierre mauroy à l'époque c'était
inévitable il était fatigué on racontait
aussi qu'il avait des petits soucis de
santé enfin il y avait une petite alerte
et puis il était épuisé et pierre mauroy
où il avait assumé la rigueur
les restructurations la sidérurgie
franchement le départ de la gauche et
tout le monde le sait était flamboyant
80 et puis à partir de 83 c'est
difficile donc le pierre mauroy il est
fatiguée un petit peu fatigué et puis au
fond
savary va démissionner et mon roi il dit
mme cissé la loi est abandonné je m'en
vais aussi et c'est courageux ses loyers
il a été loyal et
ils s'entassent 1984 c'est donc un
tournant majeur dans le septennat le
tournant majeur du septennat peut-être
on se souvient plus de celui de 83
toujours le tournant de la rigueur on ne
cesse d'évoquer quand on parle de la vie
politique française mais ce tournant de
la rigueur il a été sous la contrainte
économique évidemment et puis deuxième
tournant effectivement c'est l'école
parce que
celui là c'est une défaite politique
c'est une défaite politique le
gouvernement était obligé de renoncer à
ce qui était une ambition de la gauche
laïque enfin un peu mettront pas l'école
privée en tête ont aidé à le présenter
de lui donner de l'argent donc ça c'est
effectivement un échec politique est au
fond la sortie par cet incroyable
propositions de françois mitterrand le
référendum sur le référendum parce
qu'effectivement il n'était pas possible
de l'organiser directement sur ce sujet
a été une trouvaille politique
incroyable et le génie politique de
françois mitterrand et là c'était une
riposte aux coups de génie politique de
charles pasqua qui avait proposé au nom
de la majorité sénatoriale une motion
pour maître françois mitterrand au pied
du mur avec sa proposition de référendum
c'est le sénat en fait tu sais que tu as
eu la peau de ce projet de loi savary ou
du gouvernement mauroy et à cette
proposition de charles pasqua bon alors
pression sur le président de la
république c'est que françois mitterrand
n'avait aucune envie il a dit à l'époque
au président du sénat devrait pas tomber
comme vous avez fait tomber le général
de gaulle donc ça donnait une idée du
rapport de force mais au fond
c'est quand même charles pasqua qui
permet à françois mitterrand de trouver
la porte de sortie la plus spectaculaire
c'est à dire le référendum sur le
référendum donc on peut dire qu'il l'a
contraint mais on peut dire aussi qu'il
a aidé à sortir de ce très très mauvais
pas c'est un sujet maudit pour le
pouvoir cette bataille scolaire on en
revivre un épisode au début du
gouvernement balladur avec notamment 7
projet de révision de la loi falloux oui
c'est très difficile
jan aps colère il faut vraiment la
protéger dès qu'on touche à l'école à
l'école privée alors déjà les lois pour
tout le monde l'école publique déjà
c'est compliqué c'est toujours
extrêmement risqué pour un gouvernement
mais la mitterrand pense effectivement
qu'il a enterré chimie terminé clos la
guerre scolaire pour lui oui mais il
regardera en spectateur
balladur et françois bayrou aussi avec
un projet de loi dans l'autre sens qui
va leur causer beaucoup beaucoup de
problèmes oui une bataille qui se jouera
à front renversé puis ce sont les mecs
qu'on trouvera sont dans la rue et pour
retrouver la droite la droite catholique
ce peuple de droite dans la rue il
faudra en fait attendre près de 30 ans à
l'occasion du mariage pour tous
exactement on a retrouvé avec
l'émergence des étangs d'un mouvement
conservateur à l'occasion du mariage
pour tous la droite dans la rue à unis
globalement très unie parce que c'était
effectivement là aussi une bonne
occasion de mobiliser ses électeurs
la droite ne manifeste pas beaucoup mais
quand ils manifestent ils sont beaucoup
ils sont beaucoup très organisés et ils
sont très nombreux mais je crois que le
record de 12 juin 84 n'a jamais été un
million trois cent mille deux cent mille
on va pas chipoter
effectivement c'était c'est la
démonstration de force incroyable
[Musique]
il est des batailles qui marque qui
raconte une époque celle de l'école
libre vous l'aurez compris aura illustré
une confrontation politique un enjeu de
société un choc de conviction parce
qu'il semblait remettre en cause au fond
quelque chose de très intime le libre
choix pour chacun de l'éducation de ses
enfants le projet d'alain savary fut
enterrée avant même d'avoir pu voir le
jour en france il ne faut toucher aux
grands principes qu'avec la main
tremblante comme le disait montesquieu à
propos de la constitution
leçon politique qui résonne encore
aujourd'hui dans nos mémoires et dans
nos consciences
[Musique]
public sénat en partenariat avec le
magazine historia vous a présenté il
était une loi quand le sénat écrit
l'histoire
[Musique]